[Musica]
la storia che racconto io comincia
qualche mese fa comincia all'esordio
dell'estate del 2020 non eravamo più
uguali abbiamo scritto che tutto sarebbe
tornato uguale che ce l'avremmo fatta
ma qualcosa aveva cambiato la pelle come
serpenti non eravamo più uguale non
siamo più male eravamo reduci da una
scontata che non ci aspettavamo questa
pandemia questa emergenza sanitaria
aveva in qualche modo costretto agenti
che annullavano della consuetudine della
quotidianità la cattività domestica
stavamo chiuso in casa e stiamo chiuso
in casa anche adesso come quegli uccelli
che nella gabbia un certo punto gli aprì
lo sportello di continuano a rendere di
trans barbie è perché abbiamo preso
quell'abitudine vi a costruirci questo
tinello il cui tutto viene raccontato
per ombre come come della caverna di
platone e quindi guardavano il cinema al
computer e quindi quando voleva andare a
mangiare fuori veniva 1 con lo zaino di
saliva le scale ce lo portava e quindi
quando volevamo uscire tali mercati per
comprare qualcosa la ordinava ma e
arrivava a casa e quindi quando
cercavamo qualcuno da da da baciare da
toccare mandavamo dei messaggi ad era
gente dicono aspettavamo nemmeno quasi
da carne è
e quell'estate meno dell'anno scorso
aveva pronunciato timidamente a venir
fuori a guardarci attorno come 46 che
usciva dalle gare macerie che ti guarda
le tue produce li aveva ancora a polvere
addosso dei bombardamenti di cinema
stiamo rinascendo stiamo ricominciando e
stefania rosso
torinese bravo bravissimo l'amica mi
chiama dice guarda noi l'associazione
liberi pensatori polveri che qui è
proprio in questo quartiere inizia
millefonti
ha deciso di fare una cosa sulla
gentilezza del una settimana tutti i
racconti storie duke e della storia hai
fatto un racconto che porti in giro io
mi occupo di storia attraverso i film le
fotografie le canzoni mio figlio dice
che mi sono inventata questo mestiere
per dire che quando sto ascoltando un
disco e leggendo topolino sto lavorando
sta di fatto che mi chiama e dice guarda
facciamo una cosa sulla gentilezza che
vien da ridere a guardar per dire ma è
cosa c'entro io e non di riportare in
giro la gente per il quartiere
succederanno mille cose nel quartiere
per una settimana faremo una settimana
della gentilezza e tu racconterai
portando la gente per le strade di file
e le idee dei posti e ci saranno quelli
della fondazione architettura e faranno
vedere come è cambiata la città già come
è cambiata la città
io lo so come è cambiata la città perché
è già scritto nei libri da su boom
economico sulla crisi e me lo ricordo
questa arteria qui quella di via nizza
era una roba che che portava dalla madre
di tutte le fabbriche direttamente alla
stazione i camion carichi di macchine
però era anche la porta per entrar
torino l'inter carducci a ragazzi e
quando vedi anni 50 la città si riempie
di tutti quelli che arrivano dal nord
dal sud e paesi poveri
dalla parte povera del paese arrivano
rinunciando è ovviamente la loro lingua
rinunciando agli odori dei loro cibi
tradizionali rinunciando al santo
patrono da pregare a cui a cui
appellarsi e lasciando che quella che
era la scansione temporale tutta
affidata alle stagioni
diventassero certo punto la scansione
del loro tempo attraverso i biglietti
timbrati
la timbratura per l'accesso alla
fabbrica tutto era scandito dalla
macchina dalla produzione seriale certo
arena era un salire a due a due gradini
arrivavi dalla casa scalata verdura dove
dormire con le bestie invece di sognare
il frigorifero sognare una piccola
vettura ha dare è stato in vacanza e di
al mattino canta dello dice che
vincenzina davanti alla fabbrica nel pur
rimanendo atterrita sentito dr.d beh
allora mi sono ricordato portando in
giro la gente in questa in questo
esercizio di gentilezza che la
gentilezza una militanza e un gesto che
fa le ogni giorno e non è far
attraversare le vecchiette ma fatelo è
proprio e qualcosa per chi decide di
fare come lo scambio ripetuto e
l'opposizione al punto che pure future
premi e un'altra possibilità che ti dai
e che dovevamo darci a giugno ancora di
più per sentirci lidi e allora mentre
giravamo per le strade ma è successa una
cosa che mi era capitata mai portava in
giro gente a 10 e ambiente la 30
dovevamo avere distanziamento sembrava
un board atolli e geas regge impazzite
raccontavo storie un certo punto hanno
pronunciato l'ora del quartiere quelli
che arrivavano da fuori a dire no ma io
li miss imbracciato la prima volta che
mi racconti su diventati loro e niente
certo punto non c'erano più non
azzittito hanno cominciato a raccontare
e sembrava di rivedere le pagine di
marcovaldo perché lì ci avevo trovato in
friuli e perché gli venivano a giocare i
bambini allora mi sono messo in gioco
con una storia simile ma con la memoria
che non è la storia la la dimensione
memoriale ed ha tenuto una parte
mestiere è però mi sono ricordato allora
il mio padre quando gli anni sessanta
partito verso il nord ha sbagliato l'on
e finito in friuli eravamo l'unica
famiglia meridionale salumi invece nel
triangolo milano torino genova questa
rubrica ero l'unico bambino a scuola che
già io sono arrivato in disagio che ci
si vestiva con i vestiti dei parenti
delle e cugini lo sono pagine femmine e
quindi per integrarmi nella 3 mi manda a
scuola con questo cappotto rosso coi
bottoni dorati un colbacco sembrava un
po
una situazione era già ero già un po un
po messo da parte per come mi proponevo
attenzione mentre raccontava queste
persone dei flussi migratori mi sono
ricordato la storia mia mi sono
ricordato che quando sono arrivato a
scuola i primi giorni la maestra ha
chiamato mia mamma non mi conoscevano
nemmeno è già proposto un percorso
agevolato per me che arrivavo darci le
scuole differenziali le scuole
differenziali poi l'ho saputo dopo
studiando perché sono arrivato a torino
e studiamo dei flussi migratori facendo
un lino scudo economico ho scoperto che
ci sono faldoni così che raccontano
delle scuole differenziali che iniziano
la fine degli anni venti e arrivano fino
al 1975 attenzione all ic pass aria
quella legge che ferma la struttura
manicomiale così com'era intesa
all'epoca una roba di contenzione
dovetti legavano al letto dove ci
picchiavano ecco le scuole avevano
queste aule
dove venivano indirizzati quelli che
avevano semplici problemi di dislessia
disgrafia ma anche quelli che avevano
problemi di deambulazione perché avevano
avuto la poliomelite ma anche quelli che
non ci sentivano bene per il cile che
vanno bene quelli che avevano di evitare
una incredibile gamma di problematiche
che venivano relegati alla classe
differenziale per permettere il percorso
didattico dei normali e amici volevano
mettere perché all'epoca ancora adesso
quando faccio questo piragine e rapine
familiari le dice c'era weil hanno detto
che doveva andare alle differenziali
all'epoca la maestra aveva letto un
circolare e non ci sembrava vero di
essere al centro del mondo di poter dire
anche noi ce ne abbiamo uno a circolare
diceva lo so adesso storico che nei 40
classi differenziali di del di torino e
circondario diventano quasi 400 alla
fine degli anni sessanta ci andavano
tutti i bambini meridionali erano
sporchi perché vivevano in casa di
ringhiera che avevano un bagno da
dividere in 50mila che erano parlavano
lingue che non si capivano avevano
difficoltà a fare i conti di in una
stanza dove c'era 20 persone nelle
classi differenziali l'anticamera del
sistema manicomiale mentre giravo
raccontavo in questo racconto c'era uno
scambio che era veramente la punta senza
una gentilezza e sarà ricordato che in
quei far dormire ho trovato uno come me
che stava a torino nella zona di porta
palazzo e aveva tre anni più di me che
c'è ancora probabilmente eleggendo ma
era appassionato avevo capito finalmente
perché mi volevano mandare differenziali
avevo capito il senso della gentilezza
che qualcosa ti cancella certe ma
chiedere che ti portino esami il nome
non sono mai spiegato perché la maestra
quando dicevo ma posso andare al bagno
diceva sentite dicono bagno non capì
detto dicono è maestra un sasso sentite
bambini dicono sasso non pietà questa
condiziona hryo vis noi vede con charm
inchiodava come una farfalla il
quadretto dell'entomologo questo mestre
mastro una strada maestra
e sta di fatto che
quel ragazzo nel faldone era proprio
come figlio di operai si para ti ho
cominciato a guardare perché era una
commissione medica che ogni volta li
respingeva differenziali ogni anno come
il militare non erano dei maestri dedida
erano i medici che dicevano sa scrivere
salento del sa far di conto gli diceva
vai ce l'hai fatta quest'anno e poi il
respiro e sotto c'era nelle note ha
degli atteggiamenti antisociali ascolta
velo giro beatles e celentano che fa
ridere adesso ma voi dovete sapere che
negli anni 50 ci sono delle categorie
storiografiche che non esistono prima ai
giovani c'erano i bambini che poi erano
adulti quando funzionano a lavorare
molto cominciamo a lavorare 7 8 anni per
matt elencherò sono il vero
e poi c'era invece questa terra di mezzo
che si costruisce papi anni 50 con
questi qua dilatato adesso giovani
arrivano al pensionamento non c'è una
voragine 60 anni ma all'epoca era un
territorio una terra di mezzo dove
volevi parlare diverso da tuo padre
mangiare diverso tuo padre leggere
diverso nato parte eccolo lì aveva
respinto perché ascoltava i beatles
capelli lunghi stivaletti i bit la
ribellione
pensate il ministro degli interni il 59
si alza da registrare i parlamentari e
tuona contro i calzoni d'oltreoceano e
sono sovvertitori della nostra nella
nostra gioventù e celentano che per 24
mila baci e aveva me lo fate fare quel
movimento pelvico cazzo di questa male è
però è la stessa roba che che aveva
impedito al aveva fatto mettere un
cartello su scritto vietato e minore al
sitter perché per quanto ci giochi mia
mamma va dritta per le scommesse con noi
perché lo tieni così e fai quel
movimento pelvico che ho detto
ed è un ammiccamento e allora mi sono
detto no ma è il mio amico qua dove
adesso io che un giro e mi diceva lo
vedi quali sono le case degli istriani
andavamo a mangiare tutti e là c'era un
cinema e la gentilezza e la condivisione
perché poi la gentilezza e mettere sul
piatto quello che hai
soprattutto se diverso a quello del
codice e la condivisione e le
interazioni e parlare due lingue diverse
capello si quella la gentilezza è una
roba difficile che disfatti tutti i
denti come la felicità se c'è beh allora
io mi son detto che lo devo cercare riso
nero cercare tutti ma almeno quello mi
voglio sentire aiutavano per nel
bicchiere di vino magari non beve vino
ordinare qualcosa da mangiare magari
mangia diverso da me e guardarlo di che
fai adesso
soprattutto chiedergli scusa a nome di
tutti noi
proprio scusa da que yo ma cosa l'ho
capita
la gentilezza e dare e avere
ma soprattutto restituire
grazie
[Applauso]